-Now here's how it works.
We're each gonna take turns
drawing these cards.
Each card has five totally
random questions on it.
One person asks the questions.
The other person has to answer
each question as soon as
it's asked,
and I mean immediately. Okay?
It doesn't matter if the answer
is right or wrong.
It just has to be the
very first thing
that pops in your head, okay?
-I'm terrified.
-Phoebe,
because you are the guest,
I will read
your questions first.
-Okay.
-You ready for this? Here we go.
-Got a little lighting change?
-Oh, my God.
[ Light laughter ]
-Ready?
-Yeah.
-What's in your pocket?
-Fingerprints.
[ Laughter ]
-Where do you go when you need
to cry?
-Big balloon.
-Why did you yell at Debra?
-Because she did the thing!
-How old are most teenagers?
-Seven.
[ Laughter ]
-Tell me something cool.
-Baloo-Ba da ba-ba ba-boo.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, fantastically cool.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow, that was so cool.
-That was bizarre.
-Now, it's my turn.
Phoebe, whenever you're ready,
you can ask away.
-Okay.
-Okay, this is good, yeah.
-Did the light go down
for you as well?
-Debra knows what she did,
by the way.
-Debra does know.
-She knows what she did.
-She knows.
I have to wait for the lights?
-Here you go. Ready?
-What's your secret talent?
-I can, uh -- sing.
[ Light laughter ]
-Whose fault is it?
-Gary's.
[ Laughter ]
-When is the best time
to hug someone?
-5:00 A.M.
[ Laughter ]
-What movie will win best
picture three years from now?
-The Long Windy Place.
[ Laughter ]
-Sing your favorite salad
topping.
[ Light laughter ]
-♪ Croutons ♪
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Salad topping.
-I love it.
-Sounds like a salad dressing.
All right.
-Okay.
-This is round --
-I love this game.
-The final round in this round,
we'll both pick up a card
with the same set of questions.
We'll ask them and answer
them back and forth.
And I'll start.
Okay, ready?
-Hmm.
-What's the first thing you say
when you wake up?
-Bing!
[ Laughter ]
Why are you scared right now?
-I don't like spiders.
-Where is the best place to get
married?
-In an tiny, tiny,
tiny little box.
[ Laughter ]
What's the funniest thing you
own?
-A car.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, sorry.
What's the secret to making it
in Hollywood?
-Blinking.
[ Laughter ]
Make up a name for a song?
-"Time to get back, Jack."
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-How do you smile?
-Like -- that.
[ Laughter ]
What's another name for a horse?
-A cantor.
[ Laughter ]
Why is it so hard?
-Because it's wet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh, my God.
-That was "Think Fast"
with Phoebe Waller-Bridge.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Fleabag" is available
on Amazon Prime video.